all right let's get into these guys all
right let's see what we got all right so
man dr love go ahead and read it britney
bro you funny as hell no no go scroll
down
i want some dust yeah
here we go ah dick pic okay here we go
and dr love i've been going through it
i'm 33 years old and me and my girl just
split on new year's eve after dating for
six months not long at all
uh she said she wanted to go into the
new year with a new slate good for her
she also went to san diego on a trip
with her chick friends on new year's
definitely uh got dick uh we never had
any arguments prior we thought she might
have been pregnant
ooh the week of christmas until she
finally got her period too much info
uh we were already playing on names for
the kid stupid
and with her living la and me living in
arizona i was already contemplating
moving in my entire life to l.a
if we got the news she was pregnant okay
but she's not uh i guess she wasn't
loving the man i was becoming
any advice i love this girl and can't
lose her
she's already going um
bye felicia when he said she went on a
trip with her chick friends yeah
on new year's come on yeah you know what
those girls
she wasn't pregnant before she pregnant
one two three dick
is that what they do yeah on a night out
but um hey bro
man trust me yeah they grab their kids
they do the like again
chapelle
there's some out there that might
do listen uh what was his name don't say
his name no you can't say something oh
he can't say his name hey listen dog
listen
she's already gone yeah you're 33 years
old you're pregnant she's not pregnant
it's only six months your life
thank you six months six months six
months you're in arizona dude the honeys
out there look at your boy here
the honey's out there look at your boy
hey take it from me listen you're going
to be
fine the honeys at az look like jeremiah
he's not paying tax in arizona yeah
asu is out there i'm telling him his
girl's over it man don't come here
chasing a girl that don't want yeah bro
don't chase a girl who got a train right
now he's 33. how you know she got a
train wreck
i was with this girl for 30 years she
had a
oh hell yeah yeah let's have them zoom
into the show
wait so real quick with this guy he
actually messaged me too yeah and i
actually felt bad
because he reminds me of someone if you
go to his instagram which we're not
going to show but just to you guys i'll
show
okay he reminds us yeah totally reminds
me of somebody
do you guys notice anything about him
that looks like someone or am i just
tripping
the heart do you think he looks like jay
yeah i love him
wait what i think he looks like jay let
me see again not in that one picture
show him the one with the beanie on
oh oh yeah yeah
no i can see i can see what you're
saying yeah that's a great ovo shirt
though
yeah anyways it's not jay so yeah yeah
yeah well hey look man find love bro i
see yeah good man stay in arizona find
that love man there's
not being a deal dude yeah yeah yeah i
wouldn't even worry about old girl in la
you don't want l.a jeremiah
oh i was just looking at brendan i
realized he looks like a disney princess
you look like merida from brave oh dude
i was looking at something that's the
one with the pet uh chameleon
no that's rapunzel ah [ __ ] different one
the only thing is like your wig's a
little off your hairline
yeah just a little a little more nothing
worse when that happens
where's she from let my hair off
which is the one with the long hair uh
rapunzel this one what's that movie
it's not called rapunzel no it's called
tangled yeah that's right
that's what the chameleons tangle was
fire was good i like tangles well yeah
you don't have to put your arm around me
but yeah
you can put it back take your wig off
dog start looking like something
from the side you do it like yeah this
one says hey dr love i'm in a new
relationship and feel real happy in it
although i catch myself being jealous
over small things
because i had difficult past
relationship i never bring it up to my
new lady but wondering if you have any
tips on how i can get over jealousy
i still want my insecurities to ruin a
happy relationship you said it right
there brother
say you're not comfortable with yourself
learn who you are as a person
again love yourself first let a man
you're becoming
look at your mind he's like this guy's
seriously yeah i'm so serious
don't don't distract me i'm on a roll
listen his girl's gonna find him watch
us
like this this is
the advice these are the guys you listen
to
babe i got some real dope yeah i started
a therapist on changes i started seeing
the therapist i'm making changes okay
well who's this uh therapist
his name's dr love
let's see let's see what he looks like
and you give me right here
you gotta know who you
you'll are true to yourself you can't
wear masks you can't you're going to be
exactly who you are
gimmicks okay you got to start living
your truth your true self no more
don't disguise any part of yours
i love the transition that you're trying
to make in your life
she's all babies listen to four gay men
those are women
those are not women i just realized this
is the worst episode of the view ever
we will give you love advice we'll let
you know what's going on with your mans
and your blind
head one on there yeah that's you this
the fighter and the talk
this is i don't know the i forget don't
they switch them out
oh no they don't it's like it's like
there's a red head then there's uh
they got barbara on there barbro barbara
walters
i think she is no she's oh raven someone
who's the one in the middle that's oh
no that's not bad that's not batman
you couldn't look any more like whoopi
goldberg i told her that i told him that
you yeah hey pull up the pace at least
like her waist do you still have your
sunglasses
your glasses oh yeah put them on
chappelle but they don't they don't
oh but we need smaller ones yeah if you
rest them on the on the bridge of your
nose
yeah wrestle on the bridge your nose are
you like you like you're reading a
recipe all this [ __ ]
cat how do you guys do it you need
glasses anyway so it's good for you no
now put them down a little bit
no
those are sister facts right there
are y'all doing okay system facts uh
welcome back to the you definitely you
definitely do look like the coach of the
knicks in nineteen what was that movie
when she was the cause
eddie yeah oh yeah i'll take it
i [ __ ] with whoopi bro you remember
malcolm and eddie you gotta look like
old boy
michael jamal warner not the other one
but the dress
malcolm jamal warner okay cool how about
that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son